- All right, a very warm welcome.
Thank you for being here.
I want to start our discussion today
by sharing some scenarios
that are becoming increasingly common.
Let's say it's 8:00 a.m.
or 8:30 a.m. on a beautiful
Wednesday morning,
and Alice, your lead data
scientist, is looking
for labeled and processed images
amongst 23 million objects in her bucket.
Meanwhile, your security
team is trying to get a list
of all the objects that
have sensitive information
because your audit, because
an audit request came in
and now they're listing all of the objects
and trying to figure out which objects
have sensitive content one by one.
Does that sound familiar?
This is not a data problem.
This is a data discovery problem.
Hi, I'm Roohi Sood, and I'm a
Product Manager at Amazon S3.
I'm joined today by Claire,
our Software Development Manager,
who leads the brilliant engineering team
that has brought the vision
of accelerated object
discovery to reality.
Together, Claire and I have
just one goal for today,
to walk you through a roadmap
of how you can overcome these
data discovery challenges
in your organizations forever.
Your data scientists will get
what they need within minutes.
Your security teams will answer questions
with simple queries.
And here's our journey for today.
We'll start by diving deep
into the data discovery challenges
that are costing organizations millions
in lost opportunities.
Then Claire and I will show you
exactly how S3 Metadata
overcomes these challenges.
We will walk you through
different use cases with demos,
not theory, real examples
that you can replicate
in your own environments.
Everything that we show you
today is available right now.
You can literally enable this
before you leave Las Vegas.
And finally, we'll wrap up
with three key takeaways
that you can take back
to your organizations.
So let's start by understanding
these data discovery challenges.
We call this a challenge,
but truly these are opportunities,
one of the biggest opportunities,
and in a moment you'll understand why.
It's no surprise to anyone in this room
that data is growing faster than ever.
It's growing at a rate that was
unimaginable five years ago.
Every app you use, every car you drive,
sensors in the buildings,
every security camera,
they're all dumping data into storage.
And to put that into perspective,
Amazon S3 now stores over
500 trillion objects.
That's half a quadrillion objects.
And enter the GenAI revolution,
which has fundamentally changed
the value equation for data,
suddenly, all of that unstructured data
that's sitting in your S3
buckets, all of the videos,
the images, the logs, that's
not just storage anymore,
that's potential training
data worth millions.
But here's the challenge,
whether you are training models
or fine tuning them
or building rag use cases using
knowledge spaces, you need
to be able to identify, categorize,
and access your data sets quickly.
If your teams are spending hours
and days scouring the
data for the right videos
or identifying documents
which have the right,
which don't have sensitive
content, you're already behind.
And so this is why we call this
a data discovery opportunity
because whoever solves this
data discovery challenge
for their organizations first is going
to have an insurmountable AI advantage.
And this brings us to our
fundamental question for today.
How do I find or access
actionable data sets at scale?
The answer, as many of you
already know, is metadata.
It is the DNA of your data.
It tells you what you
have, where it is stored,
sometimes what it potentially contains,
but this is where most
organizations get stuck.
Traditional metadata solutions
typically live outside
of your storage solutions.
So they're already complex
and then they have sync issues.
Second, they're incredibly
difficult to build, operate,
and maintain at scale.
We have seen organizations
spending weeks, sometimes months
to just get the fundamental
metadata solutions right.
And finally, but the most important one,
your metadata is only
useful if it is current.
In fact, still metadata
is worse than no metadata
because it's going
to potentially lead you
down the wrong path.
And this is why we asked
ourselves this question,
what if metadata worked
just like S3, simple,
reliable, and scalable?
And this is why we created S3 Metadata.
But before I tell you
what S3 Metadata does,
I'm actually going to tell
you what it doesn't do.
It doesn't require you to
change how you work with S3
and it doesn't require you
to do any complex setups.
S3 Metadata is metadata
done right, automatic,
comprehensive, and always current.
Simply put, S3 Metadata provides
automatic metadata extraction
from your objects in S3
that you can query with
simple SQL statements.
That means every time you add an object
or you delete an object,
we automatically update your metadata.
Let's dig into why this is
exciting for customers today.
First, it captures both
system and custom metadata.
System metadata is object size,
checksum types, encryption types.
We're gonna dive into both
of these a little bit more
in our presentation today.
Second, it's built on
the Apache Iceberg format
and stored in S3 table
buckets, which means
that it's using proven
open source standards,
which you can use with any
compatible query engine
either now or in the future.
And third, it's completely automatic.
The moment you upload, update
or delete an object, your
metadata tables update as well.
There is no manual syncing required.
So how does it really work?
It's actually very simple.
All you have to do is on
your general purpose bucket,
you will add a simple
configuration that says,
that tells us you want metadata
for this particular bucket.
Once we see this configuration,
we will set up a managed
AWS S3 table bucket,
and within this table bucket,
we start populating your metadata tables.
These are called journal tables
and live inventory tables.
Now, you might be wondering,
what are these tables exactly?
What do they contain?
I'm going to invite Claire on stage
to help us understand the difference
between these metadata tables
and their different use cases.
- Thank you.
All right, thanks, Roohi.
So as Roohi mentioned,
when you enable S3 Metadata
for your bucket, we create two tables.
The first is the journal table.
You can think of the journal table
as an audit log for your bucket.
Every put, every delete,
every modification is
captured as its own row.
This isn't just metadata,
it's a time machine
for your source bucket.
You can see exactly what
happened, when it happened
and who made it happen.
Because the journal table
refreshes within minutes,
you're always working
with current information.
And this year, to make
cost management simple,
we introduced automatic
expiration of old records.
The second table is the
live inventory table.
The live inventory table
gives you a detailed view
of what's in your bucket.
You can think of it as a snapshot
of your entire data estate.
There's one row per object version.
It refreshes every hour
and it answers questions
about the state of your data.
This is perfect for
analytics and reporting.
You no longer have to issue
expensive list requests
and paginate through them,
and you no longer have to build
those complicated custom solutions
that Roohi was mentioning earlier.
It's all here and ready for you to query.
Let's take a look at this in action.
So you have a set here of users
who are all operating on a shared data set
and they are adding, updating
and deleting objects.
Now, what we can see is
because S3 Metadata is enabled,
as they're making these actions,
new rows appear in the journal
table capturing those actions
and the associated metadata.
Now, for these changes
to be reflected in your inventory table,
we run a job roughly
once an hour that's going
to read the new rows recorded
in your journal table
and apply them to your inventory table,
generating a new snapshot for your bucket.
So here we see the metadata
flowing from the journal table
into your inventory table,
creating that snapshot for you to query.
Let's take a look inside.
The schema is incredibly rich.
In total, there are 21 types
of metadata recorded in the tables.
The journal table
contains request metadata.
That's things such as record type,
request record timestamp,
requester, source IP, and system
and custom metadata are
captured in both tables.
System metadata would be
things like bucket, key,
object size, object storage class,
but also information
about encryption status,
whether the object was uploaded
using multi-part upload
and even the encryption
algorithm that was used.
Custom metadata is metadata
defined by you in the form
of user metadata or object tags.
Okay, so where do these tables live,
and how do you query them?
There are three things you need
to know about your metadata tables.
The first is that they
are Apache Iceberg format.
The second is that they are S3 Tables,
which live in S3 table buckets.
And the third is that
they're managed by AWS.
Let's break down what each of these mean.
So Apache Iceberg is an open table format
that supports SQL-like
queries over parquet data.
It's very popular.
In fact, it's one of the
fastest growing types
of data in S3.
One reason why customers
like it is it allows them,
because it's just, Iceberg
itself is just data at rest,
it allows customers to choose
which query engine they want
to use when interacting with their data.
And in fact, you may have different users
using different query engines
to access the same tables
at the same time depending
on their individual needs.
Apache Iceberg is also designed
to support analytics at scales.
It supports queries on
tables with petabytes of data
and billions of files.
It also supports functionality
such as time travel
and schema evolution capabilities.
S3 Tables is our managed
solution for Apache Iceberg.
There's few reasons why S3 Tables
is the right place for your metadata.
The first is performance.
S3 Tables offer 10 times
the transactions per second
compared to Apache Iceberg tables stored
in general purpose buckets.
The other reason is S3
Tables' deep integration
with AWS analytics solution services.
In particular, I want
to highlight the seamless integration
with AWS Lake Formation,
giving you fine grain access control
down to the row and column level.
Now, this allows you to share metadata
with several different
teams while making sure
that sensitive information
remains protected.
Okay, and then the third thing I mentioned
was that the tables were managed by AWS.
What this means is that only S3 can write
to your metadata tables,
but you still contain full access
over who can read what data.
Now, the reason we limit
the write access to S3
is so that you know
that what is in your tables
is an accurate representation
of what's in your bucket.
The second thing that managed by AWS means
is that we configure
and control the maintenance
operations on your tables.
So for example, we set the
target compaction size.
We also set configure how
frequent compaction should run.
We set up and configure
the snapshot management
and the configurations for
unreferenced file cleanup.
And we do that because
that way you don't have to,
but we also do that so we can
optimize these configurations
based off the size and structure
of your metadata tables.
Now, just yesterday, we
announced three new types
of managed tables.
You can now enable integrations
to create managed S3 Tables
for AWS CloudWatch logs,
SageMaker Unified Studio Asset Metadata
and S3 Lens data.
This is incredibly powerful.
We now have metadata from
several different AWS services
all in one place, and
since they all stored
in the same format, you
can query them together.
So how do you query your managed tables
as well as your S3 Metadata tables?
There are several different options.
The first is using AWS Analytics Services.
S3 integrates deeply with these services.
So you can use Athena Redshift,
SageMaker Unified Studio
pretty easily right out of the box.
Second is since S3 Tables supports
Iceberg Rest catalog endpoint,
you can take advantage
of the open ecosystem
of engines that support
Iceberg, whether that's DuckDB,
Apache Spark, Flink,
or Trino to name a few.
And finally, this year we
launched MCP for S3 Tables,
making it possible for you to chat
with your data using natural language.
What else can you do with your metadata?
On the screen, we have a few examples
of how you can leverage Amazon QuickSight
to visualize your metadata.
This is an easy and effective way to track
and summarize different usage
patterns in your bucket.
Okay, enough theory.
Let's talk about some use cases.
To start, let's take a second to step back
to that slide showing
what's in your metadata tables.
If you recall, there are
three types of metadata,
request metadata, custom
metadata, and system metadata.
We're gonna take a look
at each of these to see
how you can use them
to understand your data
and take action on your data.
So request metadata lives
in the journal table
and it's what you use
to inspect what's changing on your bucket.
So here we have another set of users
who are again operating
on a shared dataset.
Now, you as the owner of the
dataset, want to understand
what's changed within the past day.
You can do that by writing
a SQL query that's going
to group the results based off
of source IP and requester.
Source IP is going to
tell you the source IP
of the request, and
requester is gonna tell you
the AWS account.
For request coming from S3 Lifecycle
or other AWS services,
you're gonna see the AWS's
Services Service Principle
instead of the account ID.
Now, say you want to zero in
on a particular operation,
maybe you actually want to
understand who is deleting data.
You can do that in a couple different ways
depending on whether or not
you have versioning enabled
on your bucket.
So for an un-version bucket, you're going
to add a filter on record type,
and for a version bucket, you're going
to add an additional
filter on delete markers.
Delete markers allow you to distinguish
between permanent deletes
and the delete markers that are added
to version bucket when a
delete request is made.
So now you've understand
who has been deleting data,
you probably wanna know what
data was actually deleted,
and you just do that by
updating the select statement
to have bucket key and version ID.
Now, while you can recover
from permanent deletes
on un-version buckets, if
you have versioning enabled,
you can actually use
the output of this query
to roll back the delete requests made
by removing the delete markers.
In fact, last week we published
a tool that allows you
to do this at scale using S3 Metadata.
This tool doesn't just roll back deletes,
it can actually revert
all the changes made
as long as you have versioning
enabled on your bucket.
It does this by querying
S3 Metadata to understand
what versions existed at a particular time
and then it uses S3 batch
operations to revert those,
to the revert your bucket
back to the state that it was
by removing delete markers
and copying objects in place.
I highly recommend you all
take a look at the tool
and maybe even try it out.
Okay, so that was request metadata.
Now I'm gonna move on to system metadata.
So system metadata lives
in both your journal
and your inventory table,
and it exposes the information you need
to understand your data landscape.
For example, up on the
screen, we have a part
of an inventory table for a legacy bucket.
What we know about this bucket
is that it contains millions
of objects that have been uploaded
by different departments
over several years.
Now, last year, your compliance team
updated the policy requiring all objects
be encrypted using SSE-KMS.
Does this sound familiar to anyone?
Well, now a year later you've gone
and you've updated all of your application
to use SSE-KMS,
but you're not sure about
those objects that were created
before the policy was in place.
How are you going to find
the remaining objects
that are still using plain text?
As you can see from the
screen, it can be like looking
for a needle in a haystack.
Enter S3 Metadata.
With S3 Metadata, this
challenge is reduced
to a single pretty simple SQL query.
And what's even more exciting
is once again, you don't have
to stop here, you can take
action to encrypt these objects
by passing your output into a
batch operation, running copy
and place on these objects
and specifying your desired
encryption type as part
of the copy request.
There's one more use case
that I wanna talk about
for system metadata that
actually combine system metadata
and request metadata.
So in this example, you're
looking at who is uploading
how much data to which storage classes,
and you can do that with
the query on the screen.
Now, what's compelling about this use case
is that traditionally your access logs
and your storage data are probably stored
in two very different places
with different access controls
and probably in a different format.
And it would take actually
a significant amount
of developer effort to go
and get access to these
and combine the data into a single place
that you can now look at to
analyze this data together.
For S3 Metadata, it's all there.
One place ready to query.
Okay, so finally, the
third type of metadata,
custom metadata, which I think is one
of the most exciting parts.
It's what allows you to
enhance your metadata
with your own business context.
There are a few ways to do this.
So the first is to use user metadata.
User metadata is visible
in both the journal
and the inventory table.
To attach user metadata to an object,
you provide it as key value
pairs as part of the put request
to create an object.
And because user metadata
is specified as part
of the put request, it is immutable.
This makes it ideal
for storing information
that shouldn't change
throughout the course
of the object's lifecycle.
For example, something like the providence
or source of an object should not change
and therefore we see
customers storing this type
of information as user metadata.
The second option is to use object tags.
Object tags, you can attach object tags
to your object using object tagging APIs,
and once they're attached to the object,
they are automatically become visible
in your journal and inventory table.
Now, one other thing that is important
to understand about user metadata
and object tags is once
they're attached to the object,
they live with the object.
So if the object is copied
or replicated, the metadata,
this custom metadata is gonna go with it.
And similarly, if your object
is deleted, we will clean up
that metadata for you.
Now, finally, there's a third option,
and that is to store your custom metadata
in your own self-managed S3 table
within an S3 table bucket.
We often see customers
taking this approach
when their metadata exceeds
the size limits for tags
and user-defined metadata.
This might be to store thumbnails
or summarization of text
documents or video files.
Self-managed S3 Tables are an
incredibly flexible option,
and since they are compatible
with the same query engine tools,
you can easily combine them
with your managed metadata.
Now, a trick off with
using self-managed tables
is that updates from your buckets
aren't propagated into
your self-managed tables.
So you may have to join
your self-managed table
with your managed S3 Metadata tables
in order to understand if your
metadata is still current.
Let's take a look at a couple
use cases for custom metadata.
Something we hear from
customers all the time
is that with the explosion
of synthetic data,
they need a way to separate AI generated
versus non-AI generated metadata.
They also wanna track the
lineage of how a piece
of AI data was created.
So as part of the NOVA
launch at Reinvent last year,
Bedrock began annotating videos
and images that are uploaded
to S3 using user metadata.
The annotations indicate that
the object came from Bedrock
and the model that was
used to create them.
Now, if you have S3 Metadata
enabled, the problem
of separating AI versus
non-AI generated information
is reduced to a single SQL query.
Now, in the last example,
we talked about making sense
of data generated by AI,
but another source of growing data in S3
is from the exponential
increase of sensors
and monitors that we
see in our daily lives.
Some examples would be security
camera, vehicle sensors,
sensors on planes, ships,
and also information
from scientific studies
such as topography, data
geospatial or lunar imagery
or even DNA sequences
from genomic studies.
Now, common in all of these use cases
is that the data itself lacks
the contextual information
that's required to analyze it.
And this is particularly true
when it's first uploaded to the cloud.
For example, if you think of a sensor data
that you're uploading, you need to record
additional information such as the time
the recording might have been
made where the sensor existed
or other sensor configurations.
Now, fortunately, you can add all
of this contextual metadata to your object
and to your data through
the use of object tags.
And then once the object
tags attached to your data,
it flows through into your metadata tables
so you can find your data by querying
on that same contextual
information you attach
to your object.
All right.
I think it's time to see
some of this in action.
- All right.
We're very excited about the demo today.
Like I said, everything that we're going
to show you today is available
and you can literally on
before you leave today.
There are three parts to the demo today.
We're gonna start first by learning
how do you set up metadata
configuration on a bucket?
Then we will talk
about how you can query
those metadata tables
with different analytics engines.
And finally we'll see
how you can take storage
management actions
based on the outputs of
your metadata queries.
So let's get rolling.
Let's work on the first part,
which is setting metadata on
your general purpose buckets.
Okay.
So this is the easiest part.
You can duly set this up in
under a minute on your buckets.
All you have to do is figure
out the general purpose bucket
where you want the metadata.
In this case, we're gonna be working
on the star watcher bucket.
The two tables that we
talked about, journal
and live inventory
tables, you enable them.
You can provide the encryption types,
and the record expiration allows you
to expire the records
after a certain duration.
So let's say if you want
records older than 365 days
to be expired, you can do that.
Live inventory table is enabled.
You can again choose the
encryption type for the tables
and create your metadata configurations.
A few things that I
wanna mention over here
is once you create your
configuration, the first thing
that happens is that
your table status goes
into a creating stage.
Within a few seconds, the
journal table will become active.
Journal tables are forward
looking, they capture your puts
and deletes forward
looking, puts and deletes.
So it's active as soon as
you set up the configuration.
The live inventory table first goes
into a back filling stage
because the live inventory table
has everything about your buckets.
All of the existing objects are captured.
So it's first going to go
into the backfill stage.
This is where we get the
metadata of all of your objects
and get your ready and prepped up.
Another thing I wanna
call out is you can see
the table bucket here is AWS S3.
This is the table bucket where
all of your metadata tables,
all your journal live
inventory tables for the region
and for the account will be hosted.
So within this single
bucket you can see all
of your inventory and journal tables.
The namespace again might look familiar.
This is the, this corresponds
very closely with the name
of the bucket on which we
set up the metadata table.
It's typically, it typically
has a prefix of B underscore.
All right, so that was
all about setting up
the metadata configuration.
Next, we are going to go to
the second part of the demo,
which is how do we query
these metadata tables?
Now that we have learned
to set up these tables,
let's explore how we can
read them and query them.
So here I have both my journal
and live inventory table are active.
We're gonna start by
querying the journal table.
Today I'm going to use both
SageMaker Unified Studio
and Athena to query these tables.
We'll start by querying the journal table
and I'm using SageMaker Unified Studio.
The integration between
SageMaker Unified Studio
and S3 Table buckets is really simple.
It's a one click integration.
The first thing that we're
gonna see over here is I'd like
to show you the entire topology
that we just talked about.
So we're gonna go look up our bucket.
As you can see, the AWS
S3 Table bucket shows up,
your namespace, the which
is be underscore the name
of your bucket, and the two
tables, which is journal
and live inventory table
are showing up here.
The next thing that I
would like to show you,
this is the schema that
we just walked through
when we talked about journal
and live inventory tables.
Because this is journal, you're gonna see
the three special, the special
fields about the requester,
the request ID, the source IP address.
The scenario that I'm going
to test on the journal tables
today is show me everything
that was deleted in the past seven days
in a specific prefix.
You can filter by a lot of
additional filters here,
but I'd like to figure out
someone deleted objects
in my specific prefix.
And there we go.
Within a couple of seconds,
I have a list of everything
that was deleted
and the requester who deleted
these objects in my prefix.
This is why journal
tables are very powerful
for investigative queries,
for audit analysis,
for any time you're trying to track
what happened in my bucket and who did it.
The next part
of this demo is querying
the live inventory tables.
We are using Athena over here
to query the live inventory tables.
Live inventory tables are useful
for storage landscape analysis.
When you want to look
across your entire bucket
and see what's going on.
Here, I'd like to see everything
that has specific kinds of tags
and is in a particular storage class.
You can add additional types
of filters on encryption
on checks and types.
Here I'm trying to get a list
of all objects which meet the
object tags of a specific type
of weather and a training category.
And again, within a few
seconds I have a list
of everything without me
having to list the objects,
do the get object tagging.
I'm able to get a list
of everything that met the
specific criteria for the tags.
Another interesting thing
that I want to point out here
is that all of these objects
are in glacier storage classes,
but the metadata is queryable.
This is another powerful
aspect for S3 Metadata.
You can get metadata across
all of your objects, across all
of your storage classes and
it is instantly queryable.
We are not restoring
anything at this point
to get to this metadata.
All right, so we have done two parts
of our demo at this point.
We learned how to set
up the configuration.
We explored how can we
query both the journal
and the live inventory tables.
The third part of our demo today
is taking storage management
actions based on the outputs
of our metadata tables.
So to do this, I am going
to take another scenario.
You remember Alice, our data
scientist who was trying
to look up data for training her models?
She's actually training
a parking assist specifically
for rainy weather.
So what I want to do over
here is all of my raw data
is stored in Glacier,
and I want to restore all of that data
so it's ready for her to use.
Let's go over this quickly.
So you've seen this query before.
We just ran it on our inventory table.
We got the list
of everything which met
these specific tag criteria
in Glacier storage class.
I've limited it down to
just the bucket and the key
because that is what I need
to pass it on to a batch operations job.
The easiest way for me to
pass the output of this query
is to go to the bucket
where this output is stored.
So I'm going to the actual S3 bucket
where my query results are stored
and that is what I'm going to pass
to the batch operations job.
So my results are stored in
this training query prefix.
I'm going to go pick up the result.
I have to do one small thing
before I can use this result,
which is convert it into a format
in which batch operations job can read it.
I can do it right here.
I'm just going to
comma-separate the two values,
which is bucket and key right here
and store it as a manifest file.
So that's what we are doing here.
We're taking the output
from our metadata tables,
converting it into a comma-separated list,
storing it in this manifest file.
I'm going to go fetch the
URI for that manifest file.
And this is basically
the most important step.
You got your data, you got it prepped
and it's ready for your batch processing.
I'm going to take the URI of
this manifest file, pass it
to the batch operations job.
That's essentially the largest step
that you have with this.
Next, what we need to do, a
couple of more configurations.
Most importantly, you need
to choose the operation
that you want the batch operations job
to perform here.
We're restoring objects from
Glacier, getting them ready.
So I chose Restore.
I want them to be available for five days,
and I'd like to store,
and we're going to run
this batch operations job
at a priority.
So I'm selecting run when it's ready.
I typically like to have
my completion reports
in the same place as my manifest file.
So I'm quickly going to go
and fetch the URI of where
my completion reports sit.
So here's the URI for
my completion reports.
I'm going to patch pass this
to the batch operations job
and that's basically it.
You choose the role that
you want batch operations
to use when it's running
your restore operation
and you have set up a batch operations job
using the output of your queries.
Couple of things that you wanna look at
as you're setting up the job
is when you have the job set up,
you can see the whole manifest,
you can see the number
of objects that it is going to restore.
So let's go look
at the batch operations job
here that we just set up.
It's showing that there 88
objects in my manifest list,
they're all going to be restored.
The restore is the operation.
It's going to be restored for five days.
So this is the power of us being able
to use S3 Metadata to run
batch processing jobs.
You're no longer spending
hours time to prep your data,
you're just taking the output
of a query, processing it,
getting it ready for a batch
operations job and passing it.
And finally, for the last part
of our demo today, I'm going
to talk about querying
with natural language.
So you can ask, Claire had
mentioned there are three ways
you can query your metadata tables.
We're gonna try querying them
with natural language using
Kiro CLI and MCP for S3 Tables.
So let me start this by
first initializing Kiro.
I already have MCP for S3
Tables set up with Kiro.
So you can see that as
soon as I initialize it,
it will start loading up the
S3 Tables for MCP server.
And this is what actually enables us
to query metadata tables
using natural language,
the MCP for S3 Tables.
Now, instead of manually
creating the SQL queries,
I'm basically passing
it a prompt, telling it
to analyze my storage, go look
at all of the object counts,
the storage class
distribution, the prefixes.
And now look as Kiro interprets my request
and automatically executes the analysis.
Behind the scenes,
it's basically connecting
to S3 Metadata tables.
It's going to ask me
permissions to run a few tools,
specifically the query database.
That's where, that's the tool
it's going to go and
use to query my tables.
And now it's ready to run the SQL queries.
It's connecting to the
S3 Tables at this point,
optimizing the SQL
queries that it's running.
I also prompted Kiro
to tell me why it's
running a certain query.
So you can see first started
by looking at the count,
the size, the distribution.
Once it has that information,
it's moving on to prefixes
and finding the largest prefixes.
This is all happening without me running
a single SQL query or telling
it like what SQL do I want.
All I did was tell it exactly
what I wanted to look at.
So it's correcting, it's
looking up prefixes,
correcting the prefix analysis,
analyzing the storage
distribution per prefix.
And finally, I'm expecting
it to provide me all
of this in a summary, which
it is doing at this point.
A clean executive summary
with actionable outputs.
You can see the story,
total number of objects.
You can see the storage
class distribution,
the prefix distribution.
It's also making some
recommendations on some
of the actions that I can take.
So this is the power of
combining your S3 Metadata Tables
with with Kiro, with MCP for S3 Tables.
You're able to talk
to your metadata tables,
your business teams can talk
to your metadata tables.
You do not have to be a SQL expert.
All right, all right, so that's
metadata in action today.
The next question that
you're probably asking
is, which, where can I use it?
Which regions are we available in?
We're available in 28 regions today,
22 of which were launched
in the past week.
We are continuing to expand
our regional footprint
and are very excited.
We've covered a lot today.
We've gone about, we
talked about the challenges
and the opportunities with data discovery.
We've talked about how S3
Metadata solves these challenges.
We've seen a demo in action.
Now, I wanna talk about the real impact.
I wanna show, share with you two customer,
real world customer scenarios
where customers deployed metadata
and saw immediate results.
The first one that I want
to share is the story
of a medical imaging customer
that generates 3D models
by, from CT scans, processing thousands
of objects and files every hour.
Now, previously, this customer used Events
and they processed each file with Lambda.
This whole workflow was very fragile.
It would time out.
There was a lot of complexity involved.
When we introduced S3 Metadata Tables,
this customer completely refreshed
their job processing
pipeline with S3 Metadata.
They now use S3 Metadata journal tables.
They query, they get the query
outputs every 15 minutes,
and they use an open source
orchestration platform.
So they feed the output
of the, every 15 minutes,
they feed the output of the journal table
to the open source orchestration platform,
and that helps them batch
process their new objects.
They're now processing
thousands of files every hour,
which has dramatically reduced
their overall processing time.
This is really an impactful way
to meaningfully speed up your workflows.
The second story that I wanna share
is of a digital content
company that has millions
of articles from thousands of publishers.
Their challenge, they're moving everything
from on-premise to cloud
and they need to keep track
of these millions of files.
Imagine their different systems.
They have got old servers
databases, there's S3.
Without S3 Metadata,
this would have been a manual nightmare.
However, with S3 Metadata
inventory tables...
Sorry.
This with S3 Metadata inventory tables,
they're using simple SQL queries
to find their data based on
database IDs and migration tags.
Now they're able
to answer simple
questions like which files
were successfully updated,
which files are duplicates,
which ones we can just delete.
They're just able to
answer these questions
with simple SQL queries.
They're now moving petabytes
of data confidently full
visibility into every file
and there's no manual tracking,
no guesswork involved.
Finally, to conclude our session for today
with these impactful stories,
I also want to leave you
with three key takeaways
on how S3 Metadata will help
your organizations with data discovery.
First, it always provides
you with current metadata.
So you can stop searching
and just start querying your
tables for what you need.
Your data scientists, your security teams,
your engineers
can basically look up
information within minutes.
Second, you can, with these,
the two Iceberg-compatible
tables, the journal
and the live inventory tables,
you can now build smart workflows
and convert all of these
storage insights into actions.
You can, we saw how you can
build batch workflows at scale.
And finally, you can
future-proof your data lake.
S3 Metadata provides the
foundation for your AI agents
that can now interact
intelligently with your storage.
And here are some resources
that will help you get started
on your metadata journey.
We're very grateful to
have you all here today.
Thank you for spending the time with us,
and good luck with the rest
of your Reinvent session.
Thank you.